with an emotional story happens to be
set within an incredibly important piece
of british history it's just a story
that we were both surprised hadn't been
told in modern cinema
whenever Chris Donna makes a move you
know it's going to be prestigious to be
good to be really good when you talk
about checking the box crystal and sets
the box for everything you could do
great in an IMAX movie the shot in here
on a Mac I think are unlike anything
you've ever seen one so Chris always
likes to shoot as much possible rail
these were catching IMAX cameras to the
wings of Spitfires it's a huge huge
movie you want to create very engaging
entertainment and on a really immersive
experience I love IMAX cinema I love the
amount of information that you get and
the clarity of information one frame of
70 millimeter film is as big as your
iPhone it's that big even a big screen
is not right for this one it can IMAX
cinema for this 148 and I'm acting how
pretty
in canvas we watch the sound the vision
to smell everything is automatic
so how do i max into the victim and
you're going to don't you know if you
want cinnamon to be an immersive medium
then you know I'm actually kind of most
powerful way to do that
you